Okay, we are going to talk about a technique called
hashing, and hashing is a technique we can use
to verify the legitimacy of, of our data. So,
what is, what is, what is hashing, what is a
hash. Basically a hash is, is, is a function,
now let's call it H, that when you apply
this function to some data, you get Y. Now,
so we'll say X is some data basically you know,
ultimately a number but you know, it's, it's you know how data is presented in a
computer. Most of our functions will be dealing
with string and it returns this value Y,
which is a fixed length bit string. Usually you know on the the order of. Now,
depending on the algorithm, 32 to 256 bits,
you know, are the, are the the algorithms
we'll be dealing with. It, it can be arbitrarily
length, but the, the kind of common functions we'll be
dealing with basically take X you know data X
of any size, you know, some big, long bit string,
and returns a function, or returns a value Y
that is fixed length. and, and hashes have a lot
of uses. And they have a lot of properties
too. So let's talk about some of the properties of
this hash function H. Okay, so generally, a
property of a hash function. A good hash
function H is that for a particular value
of Y. For a particular output. It's really difficult
to find an X that'll generate that Y. You
know there is, it's, it's very difficult to find a piece of data
that hashes to something specific. Likewise, it should be infeasible, you know,
practically impossible to find a particular input X.
For particular output Y. So if we hash some
value into some you know, other value Y. We
take that other value Y and we cannot reverse
this. This means it's a, a, a one-way
function. Another property of a hash function, a good
hash function, is you can't modify X without significantly
modifying Y, and. Generally you want if you just
change one bit in X, which could be you know, thousands
of bytes long, you want Y to be completely different. And
again, this, this you know, kind of hinges on some of
these other properties as well. But basically the whole idea is that
for any particular X, you get a unique Y. You can't
get the X from that Y, and changing the X just a
little bit gives you a totally unique Y. So, there's very
little correlation between X and Y. You know, each of these properties
has a vocabulary word associated with it
and some more rigorous explanation. And if you
would like to learn about those things,
you should take CS387, which is applied cryptography.
And this is you'll learn, you'll learn
about hashes to death, we're going to use hashes
quite a bit in this lecture because it's a really handy way of verifying data.